anyone who leaves in Lagos is familiar
with this the loud gridlock of rush-hour
in my juris commercial capital
every day these vehicles discharge toxic
gases that pollute the air and escalate
global warming well there's a solution
to this problem and it's almost silent
the start button of a hybrid car like
the one that belongs to a 35 year old
entrepreneur adebola order knee care the
car runs in both petrol and electric
energy it's one of just a handful in
Nigeria basically energy comes from the
battery or the engine and you have the
converter here to convert the current to
DC to be stored inside the battery so in
this mode my batteries were charged to
hold the vehicle alongside the
passengers so as you can see the battery
is discharging the yellow arrow showing
that energy is going outside moving out
of the battery pack so the engine can
also supply power to the wheel as you
can see the engineer supplying parts
they will
most of the cars in Vegas one in petrol
or diesel both of which reduce pollution
the World Bank says Nigeria's air
quality is poor and a danger to public
health
most of those films you you see coming
out of a source contains carbon monoxide
now when the lungs is packed full of all
these things there is not enough oxygen
then there is not enough oxygen in the
system adebola is so committed to clean
energy
he's even become a mechanic of sorts I
started basically by with my love for
inverters inverters solar renewable
energy basically which was where I moved
on to hybrid they could use then
maintenance over 12 million hybrid
vehicles have been sold worldwide but
only a few of those have made their way
to Lagos the small community has created
a dedicated whatsapp group on the topic
adebola is one of its administrators we
offer fast supports two hybrid users
nationwide is not for is not for for a
fee but for forest wall encourage
ourselves and give ourselves an exchange
information visit Lee we have over six
members apart from fix in his own car he
also helps out with others like this
2010 model it's driven a bit difficult
to fix
until adebola is meeting EK the head of
the whatsapp group to get some more
advice EK a computer engineer has a
surprise in store he just bought a 2016
hybrid that he's happy to show up the
vehicle once in a more efficient energy
storage device le them ion battery
undeveloped at his hybrid second-hand it
cost two point five million naira around
several thousand dollars now that's
about half a million naira or four
hundred dollars more than
the petrol powered models although there
is still more expensive it hopes that
someday soon all the cars and his city's
roads will be hybrids are evened fully
electric